Evet bugünkü davranıyor tam olmaktan
dolayı son derece heyecanlıyım ve ve çok
da mutluyum bildiğiniz gibi tamamız biz
o
Bu ancak bazılarına söylemek bir o kadar
zor ki ağzınıza cam kırıkları
varmışçasına acı veriyorlar konuşurken
var Çünkü ben acıları gerçek hayatta
görmektense konuşmayı tercih ederim
bugün de
[Müzik]
abone ol
o laflar en gençler dedim çünkü benzerin
hayatınızda sonra ne olduğunu
düşünüyorum Ben televizyon çok fazla
izlemiyorum Hatta Son dört aydır hiç
izlemiyorum diyebilirim haberleri sosyal
medya platformlarından farklı etmeyi
tercih ediyorum ve sadece yarışma
programı o
ve salı çarşamba perşembe şeyler
yapıyoruz a Cuma gidiyor Şimdi izliyoruz
yapıyoruz bu arada gerçekleşir mi
Ben askere Evet onu gördüm Başka var mı
Evet evet aparat sürü ve şeyi Ancak
bugün
bu küçük ve orta büyüklükteki ekranlar
Yani akıllı telefonlarımız Ahmet ederiz
bilgisayarınız
ve sosyal medya kullanıcı oranı şu anda
Türkiye'de nüfusun yüzde 53'ü ve bu
Arapça o kadar artıyor kolları atacağım
sosyal medya kullanım oranı artıyor e199
civarında kesinlikle noktam hangisi daha
fazla yada az izliyoruz Çok izliyoruz
değil bir şekilde maruz kalıyoruz o
bu Ama bunlar Peki neler yapıyor
olabilirler vatandaşları bireylere
gerçek hayatta görebilecekleri
zararlardan korunmak için yapıyorlar
bunu En azından buna inanmamızı
istiyorlar Peki olduğunuzu varsayıyorum
bu düşünceler neden gerçek hayatta
insanın insana haksızlığın karşısında
aynı önlemler alınıyor bu tek
bu saatler kalıyorum mafyaları havalı
gösterildiği sahneler geldi özetlemek
istiyorum yerleşmiş değil mi
Ah ah dizinleri görüyoruz Evet abla
gençler Ergenç o gelmeden olsun 200 bin
adet şiddet sadece televizyonlarda o
16 arasındaki vakit gelir Biz bu
konuşmayı yapamayız hatta hatta
Şu anda öyle konuşmayı yapamayız nedir
Bir uyandırma daha bu değiştirecek
olanları gizler olduğu karşısındayım
buradaki değerli İnsanlar daha sonra
olan duyarlılığını sağlar şu anda aynı
anda 4 tane örnek var Bunları sizinle
paylaşmak istiyorum Bunlar konuşmama
öğrenci olduklarını düşündüğüm filmler
12 yeşil renkler işi rehberde öksürüğü
konusu işleniyor Biz evlendiyse ölçülü
ve o
ya ben çok daha rahat
O çok daha rahat Ahmet diyeceğim de o
insanlar da yaparım Burası cevizi
Allah'ın olaylar İkincisi ise bu kadar
paspas olayların nasıl bir şekilde zarar
bir şekilde işlere bizlere düşünmeye
empati kurmaya sever edeceklerin çok iyi
ornekleri olduğunu da
Evet Ee İstanbul aklını kullanan biraz
biraz olacak ancak bu ellerim çok
değerli olduğunu yazıyorum şimdi şöyle
bir araştırma yapıyoruz ve belli değil
Çok da soruyor ki ekranlarınıza
gösterilen sahnelerden rahatsız mısınız
Evet diyenlere hamzah nelerden
rahatsınız diye soruyor ve bu insanların
49'u ekranlarda gösterilen şimdiden
yüzde 35'i ise kadına yönelik
istismardan rahatsız olduklarını
söylüyorlar Evet yüzer zarını gösterilir
ancak da dikkat çekmeyen yüzüne bakmak
istiyorum
abone ol
var ya şu anlama geliyor bu insanları
yüzde 51'e televizyonlarda gösterilen o
şifre sahnelerinden asla rahatsız
Beylerbeyi'nde 65'li 65'e adına göre
istismardan rahatsız değiller
ekranlarınıza gösterilen Bugün aslında
gözüküyor gözüküyor çünkü bu rahatsız
olmayan insanların bu davranışları
normalleştirilmiş olma ihtimalleri var
ve bu o
ve bu yere bir çoğunuz araçla olduğu bir
yere bir diye düşünüyorum çeşitli sosyal
medya platformlarında buna benzer
uyarılar çıkıyor gönderelim gönderilerin
içeriklerine göre bu fotoğrafta Bazı
insanların saldırgan kırıcı veya
rahatsız edici bulabileceği çiçekler var
da o
a Walk Allah razı insanların rahatsız
verecek saldırgan Kırıcı bulabileceği
nasıl içerikler var Neden toplumda Çünkü
aslında bizim O gördüğünüz Görüntüler
var evlerinde gerçekten düşünüyorum
kuramıyoruz ekranınızın arkasında da
bu daha sonra yeter vermem gerekirse
Merhaba 23 73 duyurusunda bulunmasına
rağmen biz oğlum vahşice öldürüldü
olarak okuyoruz ya
bu bahşişleri kafasında şunun o
canlandığını düşünebiliyorum anlattım
yani adımlarına çünkü Boğazı hiç bir
şekilde o
o zamanın nasıl düzleştirilir bunları
düşüneceğiz
bu farkında olup farkındalık yazacağız
bize bize de çıkıyorum arkadaşlarımız
atarak şeyler de ediyor diye Onun
söylediğine Cuma kabul etmeyeceğiz
kuracağız bu noktada çok sevdiğim bir
şeyi paylaşmak istiyorum rahat oldu Evet
konuşmasında geçen mı
Uğur Bayar verebiliyorum bu
ulaştığınızda bunu mutfağınızda
okursanız diye bulan bir Okulu açılan
birleştiği ve güzelliği konuşmaya
görevlerinden bir soru soracağım Bu
kadar konuşuyorum her zaman yapabiliyor
muyum Maalesef o
de içinde bulunduğu Avrupa gençlik
parlamentosu aracılığıyla bölgede
dönmeye çalışıyorum farklı unsuru olan
her şeyin o
bu hakkında iki sahibi oldular bu
sorunları yaşayan kişilerle çok daha
rahat teknoloji kuruyorlar ve hatta
belki gerçek hayatlarını yazıyorlardı
Böylece aktif vatandaşlar oluyorlar ve
ve sosyal Adalet Bize en iyi şekilde
kavruldu var benim son bir sorum olacak
bugün çok soru sordum Bu da farklı
görüşler var aslında elbise çıkan ama şu
an değerlendirelim Biz biz muyuz
ve benzeri zaman değilim olan biz
değilse Bunu oraya hakkımız yok görmedim
yok gördüm duymadım yok duydum
bilmiyorum geliyorum ve aksiyon
yaşıyorum yani ne olursa olsun güzelden
aklından alacağız fakat görüşeceğiz bu
yolda mı
Allah Allah ağabey olmaz ve sağlık
istemiyorsun evde çok teşekkür ederim ya